hey guys healthy guy and today we're
gonna be making some dirt cake I've got
a flowerpot which an actual plastic
flower pot well yeah but if you can't
put dirt in it cuz it's gonna go through
it yeah I'll put it all up put it on a
mall this give that actually I like that
oil idea that wasn't what I had in mind
at all
now you have mine no we get rid of the
inside of it no yeah but no why would
you do that that's the best part
okay do you get rid of the inside I
don't know I don't think you should do
that stupid this crazy because actually
says to use a food processor I'm using
this for what it's intended hazley mixer
oh I was drunk that on my head this was
in my husband last month alright I'm
ready to give us a nice swift blend whoa
I don't know heavy a little bit more
than one call it I have mix but do
anything else
Oh that already started to go this
doesn't even walked just like with the
milk and pudding mix for two minutes
three and a half cups one milk this is
about a Dairy three in 1/3 Scott how
much was that two cups swash cuz you're
not just doing this okay wait I don't
like it let's stop this this oh no this
is like mud this is mud do you think we
should blend it we should probably blend
it was actually looks like actually we
just need that Oh Oh is this heavy you
need help my one arm is what's wrong
enough Oh sounds like mana
oh holy a punk wait when do we hold in
the food after this is all mixed
together I must say I am locked was
locked out I don't know
hold in whip topic we have to put it in
how much and put in I don't think you
should put it in that like you should
put it in here no I can mix it better
but I thought we're going to put the
whole final thing in here let's do this
it'll be really quick it'll be on can
you get that okay thank you
you know this is honestly the best thing
actually we can fold it it's really
going well I mean when I thought about
the cake this together look at this cake
in bigger right better I don't know it's
okay for you it's fine ah you know what
not shoots now it's everywhere we have
to fold it in that's not all you fold
your right just dump it in I'm getting
impatient okay just dumping it just up
in it I don't know did you wonder what's
the next ingredient oh that is so liquid
even vomit hmm man you ruin everything
that I'm excited about this happened
here what has happened here look why is
this like what well you're not supposed
to do that I'm supposed to sit on top of
it this is on top of it really well I
don't know maybe you are supposed to ah
I'm not sure yeah I'm I'm the one who
messed up it will sit on top of it
because it's also sitting liquid oh okay
you're right mix it up so now we just
okay no more mixing maybe we wanted to
mix this up Dermott this is mad you've
made a crater in your creation
ready Oh nobody oh I always remember I
was little this used to be sir oh yeah
all right now for the final touch the
worms hopefully like to swim where'd
they go you're over there so this is
supposed to be fat-free gluten-free
low-sodium worms good
what happened here oh yeah gluten-free
gonna drown
oh he's drowning somebody say the ratio
of like stuff to Oreo isn't that's a Oh
other items sure I did here just seems
said before this video I can't wait to
actually eat this I was seriously so
excited about it trying to eat until
serving oh we're not done with that it's
good I think if I refrigerate it yeah
let's refrigerate it one first I want to
eat another bite we don't want that
chill oh my god I was burned my hand
finish another video that were working
on okay well God everything in the
fridge just and here's this spinning
here hurt a two hours and still jiggly
alright
nothing wrong with a little jiggle I
think already for this jiggle I don't
think you're ready for hmm
well thank you guys so much for watching
not very in the pot I can't put it in
the pot this is so watery it'll go right
through the holes here's the hole did
you check it out yeah I took off the
foil I don't remember doing hot
yeah it's a little bit chilled see you
look much better consistency maybe
measures you put it in freezer
oh good already thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed our video
and really sorry attempt to make a dirt
cake I think if we chilled this maybe
overnight it'll be a little bit better
in the morning let me know in the
comments below what you guys would like
to see me or génifique next make sure
you check out her channel it's me Jenna
E
and we'll see you in our next video I'm
so tempted to just take this and dump it
on your head I don't know why I just
want to like just do it
could you imagine I think I would have
to go into it that's not what you
imagine that's how God will be sick